romantic there are many events to refer
to as it's very important to sort of
scenarios the event on februari 1514
more effective turbo making an
announcement in mazi speaking on behalf
of the I was being the massacre families
victims families
where he was speaking I think I know
what it wasn't I buzzy was a one of
something called this social networks
organization they had gone to unlock
that we've gone to save gone to safety
when arrives they had been to the
Ministry of Justice they talked to
several and the last place they were
pushed into was this clear that the
Chevy I think it was the sort of a top
in our leadership that you need a union
and it sort of the social services
division of their basically these
families were suffering they wanted some
more than anything I think they wanted
acknowledgment and they wanted the
location of the bodies of work of the
death of that mask 1996 and also they
wanted some help and so we're fat liter
burrell had given the speech I think
they had approached this this
organization and basically they were
they would never go to give it anything
in writing and so he made a speech was
recorded it went on the net he was
immediately arrested upon his arrest
people came out on you stated my fuzzy
several people were killed and then
Driessen was Mara was arrested in sort
of it continued but I want to go back to
something to event a few days before the
big combination of gaddafi's Town Hall
sort of democratic system are these town
hall meeting that usually happen in
December attended by very very few
people and where you know people are
told to shut down their stores and they
must go and attend and I've seen this
cat and mouse game in Benghazi with my
brother his own story the story's
halfway shot if you want to buy a tire
you have to sort of come in and they
open it and they cv the house better be
or a local guards telling people to shut
down and they shut down and they open
and no one knows who these me but cadet
he likes to attend one year he attended
as part of the audience and he was of
course nobody looked at that people at
the table ever but the whole camera went
to the audience one night where we are
but this year he went to set up of
course this was doing in the Tunisian
and I looked for it in for the two
actual villain together exactly during
the Tunisian crisis maybe before his
Melody's gone speech you should have
revolted against them and but what
happened was that he had come to
presided over this town hall meeting and
to me that that event has a lot to say
what the video recorded was a young man
speaking saying great leader there are
apartments there's housing needed in
seta we need them we have signed for
these apartments to be given to us and
we have not received them and Qaddafi
asked this young ambassador who are you
where are you from what tribe oh this
time are you affiliated to this other
tribe when did you give Ian not Libyan
and he said we're Libyan Libyan we came
from Chad 1981 or early 80s at all and
so okay you want to be in fine so in a
sense or like okay you are living so
there is no idea of how could that
between the Libyan citizenship may be as
well to sort of impromptu treatment of
it and he was looking into
papers on do not have inverses on and
then there was a someone from the seller
sort of your critique group or the
popular committee and that yes and so
why don't you give them the apartment
and he said well the apartments that are
not completed that list is long and
there are two things to be to be aware
of here that the bureaucrat could be
either of two things maybe another one
is it it's true the apartments could not
have been married maybe they're they
remember going to be completed there are
so many projects that had been good
Olivia that never got completed in the
city of San hub there were schools that
have gotten second contacts to be
refurbished after 20 years old but then
they discovered that the school never
existed to begin with and so that and
then some cities were even more coming
and so what this gentleman who was
wearing a headpiece looked like a server
and earlier cotati freshman you want to
say no his company the truth is that the
apartments could not have been ready or
that the government has ceased to give
them I actually work as i was in Tripoli
two months ago and somebody said oh
armstrong consultation group poor guys
Qaddafi hasn't paid them to be huge
American consultative group that gets a
lot of money and even they are conveying
that is not so Qaddafi doesn't pay they
never finished projects on the other
thing that could be possible that this
bureaucrat is you know that's his time
to make a cut that's how you make a
living as a yoga if you had a bit health
unit or a school unit or a husband you
division level when do you get to sell
the by purchase goods from Germany or
Italy or whatever and when you get to do
that that's when you get to make you
make you big cut and so you live on a
salary of two hundred dollars for all of
your bureaucratic career but every now
and then you go and they send you to
Italy or to some place will you McMahon
a negotiated with a Turkish or German or
whatever company and you make a few
million colors and that's why you never
want to leave that job because you want
to hold that position so you know I
don't know that details of what happens
that I was then the bureaucrat was he
not able to actually finish this project
because they
treszura never paint or is the project
not finished because the bureaucrats
were waiting for the contracts in
topanga and it could be either one but
that's the system that it happened now
what Qaddafi did was said ok so what
happened to these people why didn't I
get their apartments when they get them
and there was some insufficient to
invest why don't the people who have the
apartments get them why don't you go and
go get the apartments and the whole
erupted who was like Oprah everybody was
going to get an apartment and then the
meeting he think they began to chant for
him he began pumping his fist and he
just kind of walked out of the meeting
and then the guy using meeting in order
come back and of course it was a circus
could that mean solve the problem he was
going to divide the apartment Cesare
well the thing that was going to happen
was that these people that were promised
apartments I'm not likely to get them
they would have to call on Qaddafi again
and again to remind him that he had
promised them their parties but these
bureaucrats have some pressure on the 40
weeks to deliver this ongoing sort of
process where there is a
a cat and mouse game between people
between them and resources of the of
their governments continuously
struggling to get them is an everyday
occurrence the fact that there are
people who are living a certain power
that is totally aligned with Qaddafi and
the fact that Qaddafi can get involved
in the smallest details I mean people
who had needed cars we were trying to
call / happy to get them you know you
just didn't go to your fellow citizen
who's in the booth you went to as high
as you could when I was in Benghazi few
years ago time to get my driver's
license which was a cold sweet are they
there were people who were trying to get
permission to wear sandals while driving
because it was against allowed to drive
aware
Olivia and they didn't go to somebody
they went to the head of the miscibility
of Benghazi's traffic unity this is
somebody who covers an area of maybe 200
square miles and they were all you know
sort of on him to try to get this permit
because yes it is absurd but if you got
a ticket for something like this it can
be very expensive you could never have
to pay for and so basically people were
sort of i'm sorry the different ticket I
never wore sandals but a good amount for
and so the idea of nothing happening
without somebody in power is it a high
solving the problem is part of the chaos
now of course the other thing I
mentioned was this Libyan weather who's
living and not leaving it's something
that it can be played with we saw that
some of these have some mercenary some
other had been granted citizenship right
on the spot and so this has become fluid
and because
been very open to negotiation as far as
the government delivery that's something
that people had suffered from now what
happened the day after this capricious
positioning this moment of everyone
getting and it's reminded people of
something that happened 30 years ago
when in cadavers green book where the
statement was the house to whoever
resides in it was the declaration it
meant that there are no more rental
properties basically if you are
graduating from someone basically you
just stay and keep the house I'm sure
that's something we'd all love to do but
it did create a lot of chaos in Libya at
the time because it it mended actually
people were taking over other people's
travel property when they will know God
and it created lots of difficulties
people it also allowed the Revolutionary
Committees that people were highly
connected to actually possessed property
to in the name of of the revolution and
so on as if you were and if you become
the enemy of the state immediately for
it or another your part to escape but
what happened was Benghazi and in there
man other places people did go to these
apartments to take over some of them
were not finished then the people who
had actually been given certificates to
have been waiting for years to receive
government apartments or saying when we
we have them in a wide view get and so
this time around it's into it clear that
this was a ploy and it didn't work
because I think that that may have been
one of the first moments of actual
popular resistance because these people
stayed in the apartments then the people
who were wiped or at least guarantees
please the partners there was a
negotiation between them some of them
cold out some of them didn't but they
were people who stayed in so there was a
sort of a stick in
for these apartments the problem of
course also is that the demand now for
housing in Libya for young people is
much harder the income when you were a
government employee without housing in
1979 you a salary would have been about
six hundred and fifty dollars at the
time if you were living on a salary if
you had a job if you had a job and you
were to become a government salary your
income now would be about 160 current up
so you could imagine six hundred fifty
dollars 1979 140 150 dollars now and so
things are much worse the top sellers
have been frozen for all of these 30
years so the spark was what I would say
is a part of a ser understand which is
where the magic of the magic or the
magical powers have turned against the
musician and people felt but now they
could resist this was a moment when they
can stand their ground and it was the
people negotiating between them what is
right and that we had tried to start a
ploy to divide people and somehow the
local people in
decided well no this is not the correct
thing to do and so by not having the
magician solve the problem was at the
source of confidence now to go back a
little bit as to some of the other sort
of tensions if i were to all the sort of
the historical moments in the sto if i
were to go back to a another magical
moment perhaps in libya sister i would
go back to nineteen eighty-eight which
would have been
maybe april nineteen eighty something
called as possible morning has broken i
guess how did you call when Qaddafi had
brought down the prison he wrote a
caterpillar and parade came the
caterpillar and down prison which is
called its popular name is hassan
desperate so the black horse was
officially and he said no prisoners and
the name of us was super over the
morning what has come on
he comes from a song by Cellini
significant love the great deal and he
took down that prison and released the
political prisoners would be held from
well in some of them from nineteen
eighty one of the people was released
was a moose Ahmed was attempted coup on
in nineteen seventy so leftist and
Baptist or at least some wine were
released by then you hadn't had the
militant Islamist at work have in the
1990s and maybe some heroin bugs were
released but like a whole generation of
perhaps discredited ID auditions were
released and but what 1980 marked was
from from denham the violence committed
against the population was no longer
made public you have more conserve
denial in 1979 there were public
hangings in Benghazi those were things
that the reason was very proud of they
were shown on television repeatedly to
scare population the disappearance of
one superior like the world was never
working class and this is sort of what
would 1988 may have lent for the regime
the again there were assassination in
terms of Qaddafi 1984 those people were
hung publicly with was closed locked
maybe there was a very thin that and
when they're kind of didn't work they
were members of the Revolutionary
Committees pulling these people from the
legs to make sure that i suffocated yep
well obviously was never you guys never
acknowledged by their given to the years
later and the bodies were never met in
fact people who were considered the
opposition were not granted the right to
be buried in Libya and there were
instances of opposition people or what
to be very the bigger and their corpses
were taken to be thrown back into the
sea well this is this was not
we can't happen the regime's virus did
not end but 1988 marked a change but now
by then to win by then of course the all
of the that is Arabist Arabist cryptic
Street credit is gone his support of the
Palestinians and by then moved to a
month another other initiatives that
were forthcoming were also proven to be
background now what we've come to now I
guess at this moment is really adapting
Qaddafi stress and those of his sons one
is that Qaddafi has had a hole he's
coming back to those moments in the late
seventies and early eighties when he
basically hit people with with iron and
fire what also happened that his son who
was safe as Jordan I think this notion
would have been
that he could perhaps rule over a kind
of right-wing chili in Salvador where
you could grant people some mother come
of high-end committee will but then you
you couldn't they wouldn't be granted
freedom presence on the the exposure
that Libyans accuracy since the 1990s
they had really had been a North Korea's
the government from 80s and most of the
90s what made that impossible
communications they tied not to have
cell phone didn't for the longest time
but it didn't work I think we should
just stop for a moment so we can really
get some serious questions in because
we've only got about a half hour left
there's a microphone here which would
help if you can get to the microphone
unless you've got a very loud voice so
when we start over there and then over
here
hi thank you all pretty much simple you
mentioned sort of idea that tribalism is
not very revealing way to understand the
various fractures and Libyan society
especially in the contemporary political
moment it also strikes me that sort of a
simple mask populism of you know the
people versus the regime isn't
necessarily so revealing so I was just
wondering if any if you could sort of
comment on what you see as the sort of
fractures right now politically given
the current situation right okay the
problem with what do you say of Libya
has types you know ask myself what does
it mean how is it being defined is it
really a tribal organization that
existed in 2050 is it means that people
are autonomous from the state does it
mean that the tribe is really not
integrated in the modern economy what
does it mean it's very confusing
reduction is simple but very very much
confusing term now tribes and clans up
do existing legal society
but also their role today is different
from what used to be 50 or 40 years ago
or us 70 years ago you know what we have
to understand is when when the regime
has made since the nineteen seventy
principal parties unfortunately also the
monarchy you know bad political parties
and with the regime began to really
weaken and then destroy all independent
trade unions and professional
organizations for example just give you
a case in point Libya and I was part of
that that that movement in the late
seventies had one of the best student
independent organization and the whole
region it was taken you know um by
demonstration and bike also by blood by
many students with administrate in 1964
and the monarchy granted the students
and independent trade union dad that
very militant very good organized very
democratic Jade union was you know
destroy it physically in 1976 and the so
called the students revolution of sahabi
or set the April
the army and the facts of the regime
attack the university's kills some of
this suit leaders arrested others and
pump than all kind of organizations and
some they had to stay in exile it's at
that time now the the fact that the
state did not tolerate any of this
organization that existed either Royals
hills you know labor union student
unions other other associations most of
the kids were left with that is original
formal institutions the mosque and your
own extended family or tribe or clan and
it's natural that you mean on them now
you know when you define it in that
sense it does they do exist in Libya
today but when you reduce the pesticides
Oh tribes often us they call me
sometimes they are they were professor
Anita what kind of chopsticks is there
as this is trillion mogera how or this
is the so-and-so and so-and-so and I go
crazy I say
talk about this go to your homework so
this is the trouble with it and
unfortunately is so pervasive that its
people now accepted as a fact and only
by critically thinking about these
assumptions and locate these kinship
organization in the larger context of
urban and other organizations and with
the upon meeting we could understand
that Libya yes it's a huge country that
is a fourth largest country and us after
that the dependence of southern Sudan
could be the third large cousin Olivia
and as in any other country has regional
diversity in general in a bum accent
chairman Tom you know I'm a little bit
but also olivia is very integrated since
the last year boxes in the venison 51
and already by locating the diversity of
Libyan modern us association traditional
associations all these are groupings
that then can make sense of them but to
say Oh tribal divisions it gives you a
clear answer for the buzz explain onion
and the car
estate a hindrance and a confusing
announcer thank you very much question
here I think one of the major problems
now is that Ezeli has no safe exit Ethan
Feliz for exile he knows now that would
be possible by the ICC a no combo for
crimes against humanity so the most
dangerous thing that out if that is in a
kill or die situation so how do you see
it involvement especially that you know
he himself warned about a civil war and
then Hillary Clinton worn out a bigger
so money so you see this happening as a
possibility where they are maybe
Kentucky's they much more of a unifying
figure man anything because so reviled
by so many people that
that in itself actually can guarantee a
model of national unity I think there's
a lot to think about in terms of to
continue what are you saying is that
there's there's a lot of these forty
years have a great many moments of
simultaneity these moments of watching
the hangings as one nation that sort of
a national trauma how a sense of that
the fire potential that's that's one
healing that all people I think you need
a or gradient and also I think people
living they say but as I said Libya
Tunisia and we're not in and he's right
exactly people live in this feel like
we're about Tunisia or not egypt and the
type of radiation that is at work is not
sufficient the truth is if anybody in
your tribe could help you if they were
in the Revolutionary Committee the share
of your tribe could not possibly believe
you happiness is that somebody in
Kentucky stalking and political tracking
so the oil is perhaps an organizing
factor because that's a centralized
a source of income and so far that
hasn't been divided I don't think that
that's going to be easily divided in the
air among the East or the west so as far
as Libya becoming Somalia adopted so
that I think the Somalis swept into
little groups because they had to really
fend for themselves and perhaps in the
most desperate ways but Olivia the
structure the structure of the book of
the oil system is a centralized factor
and I think there is a sense of being an
arm's never been thought of in any
tribal terms it's so it's so it happens
to be inland that don't belong to any
particular time that i know but i don't
think i've heard people have been saying
that this belongs to us or so in a sense
the arm is probably as much of a
unifying source as any what will adapt
do i think the coordination that's going
to need to happen between the elements
that are
as yeast and then the coordination that
they make with the West the western
parts is going to decide on that but
subsidy enough at you that adapt his
persistence in power is may actually
sort of unify the country around him
rather than divide this is quick respond
to Muhammad as a question I think so
clean up the weather samatha Lydia would
become another Somalia that's a
possibility Iraq was unified urban
secular and look what what happened in
Iraq gutted and see to tribals and
sectarianism and so many things we never
ever caught up so I think in society is
these things possible it's not
inconceivable but I think hard as right
in the sense that the d dis beaches the
discussions the statement we have you
know been hearing from eastern Libya
from Misrata from cellular from other
parts of India actually are in a very
very very much for you know five country
or a different kind
or a hopeful country and awareness even
in the East region which is historically
has been marginalized and historically
has been its Oh has its own kind of own
in our psyches about the central
government especially after 1969 it has
been really emphasizing tripolis our
capital we want the libby of the future
we are capable of doing that and we want
a unified observant oblivion now what
worries me is that the discussion so far
which is a human everybody is talking
about it in great of the dictatorship
which is right but this has been said
about what are the Indians for what what
kind of absurd I think that's
understandable to raise that it depends
effect which is you know simple laws a
lot from Lydia's goodly good days now
but what also what kind of five or six
demands are gonna you know what we're
going to do about the Constitution
what's that having to leave here after
Gadhafi and these are hard question it's
not you know enough to say that just
what I get you into the container ship
and everything is going to be good I
think that's really Harris but naive may
be human but naive and it would be good
to UM to encourage that debate to come
out and one more thing is also important
and I said it in an amendment reviews I
think we should respect the leadership
and the youth who are leading the revolt
the excited community should support
that but should stay out of it and we
may have been a dick the solution
looking for our what people are you know
undergone to create this evolution
there's the internet there's technology
there is communication I mean a lot of
the mindset is it is an urban violence
and and also the fact that people is
young what work I don't think that the
tribal configurations that are that we
that people may think of our are going
to be savvy enough to provide jobs or
work that demands a kind of stability
and contact with technology and contact
with ya and markets and creating of Mars
and in a sense that that's that
tribalism would would not I think then
kind of like the life that the young
people are looking for it is not I think
that can be provided by the destruction
which might be a change in living
history look at history very briefly up
to 1931 idibia has been dominated by
society or the state this is different
from agent that a professor our
grandma's talk about Libya until nine th
e one until the crushing of the last
pocket of resistance was dominated by
the countryside we could say that the
society was stronger than the state and
it's no secret you think about it Martin
Lydia post-colonial Divya two leaders is
where they come from from the
countryside indeed reason the grandson
of the great brilliant scholar of 19th
century Mohammad Nassir Lucy who founded
a remarkable modern movement based on
indication and trade and after that it
that he also came from the countryside I
think her observation is accurate
because we might see now something
coming from the urban modern sector of
the society and as a matter
I think Libyan tribes are weakened in
the captivate
yes
very much dr. Ali I mentioned a couple
of times now the flag and I was hoping
we could talk a little bit more about
that why do you think people have
latched on to the flag of the senesi
monarch as a symbol of this moment is it
just because it's the only symbol they
had access to of a unified Libya that
had nothing to do with Kadafi or is this
actually speaking to some kind of
revitalization of the idea of ascent of
sia as liberators of libya and a related
question which i don't expect anyone can
actually answer right knows where did
all of these flags come from all of the
sons we have all of these flags who's
producing them and who decided that this
would be the big symbol of Illinois well
let's try the second one I so I by the
Libyan American colleague with the aflac
you could answer for us because he has a
one I think there and apparently some of
them are printed here in America some
are at home I don't know this is an
empirical question I did not really what
are the blood the first question I think
as a very good one I I can make to a
possible answer for your question the
first one when you look at how Liddy
ended by ruled by a very very bankrupt
exhausted you know authoritarian state
with a very
social base headed by somebody who's now
the king of kings of Africa he's turned
in a transformed from what they're good
you know the perimeter or revolutionary
or making if kings so that kid gives you
an idea management now most Libyans
human being when they they think about
their fathers their grandfathers and
their mothers and grandmothers the
monarchy looks really peaceful and looks
modernizing would always its mistakes
and flaws and contradictions it was the
only two decades that Libyan people who
really we should pity them they had
horrible 20 century a horrible to nature
and I spent my whole life trying to
write about how brutal and how
devastating the colonization Libya was
you talking about almost half of the
population half a million people
perished during the 40 days of
colonization and sixty thousand of them
and I'm writing a book about that
perished in concentration camps before
even the Holocaust under Italian fascist
regime the flag symbolically was made
because yes the latest group of people
notable tribal chiefs and urban of folks
and so but it was you know
and chosen by an assembly a general
assembling of Libyan elite that time and
it was people liked it because many many
Libyans including my generations and
mental under for me and after me it was
the flag that symbolized linear
independence which was with all its
limitation was a major achievement I
think symbolically Libyans see this as
as a source of defiance against how
things how about these are today also
they see that as a wave of nostalgia for
our the good times and as the Iranian
people I mean I would you have to know
that the Iranian struggle against the
Shah has dictatorship what was the major
Ferris demand for them the
constitutional of 1905 revolution so
Libyans symbolically I think that
nostalgic first now I do have a caution
and worry we don't have a ro in this
opposition to now no matter how good and
there is you know point for that that
the monarchy years are were going back
would be in a huge mistake because I you
know the challenge for then again people
to overcome the monarchy and the king of
kings
as well you look for the future and
that's going to take a lot of hard work
that beyond just then protesting and
trying to topple a regime that's really
now against the worlds of the majority
of the news just add our mutual friend
historian in 30 2010 article about Libya
and the 1930s and he was immediately
interrogated you were not allowed as a
Libyan to write anything about the
period of colonization that was somewhat
positive nothing industries absolutely
his name was not could not be mentioned
in Libya and any sort of text so in a
sense you had a total suppression of of
that era the other thing is before this
ugly conducting on country 17 you had
Libya he end up with a flag I was red
white and black very much like the
egyptian and I think in not going to a
flag that he chosen whether it was
degree or the earlier one not only is a
rejection of anything Ian work to the
and I think it must have been a huge
disappointment a fee to be silent so we
but also I think the idea of them we are
not Egypt it is also important that we
have history that's different idea of
not Egypt not Finizio and to bring this
black that would infuriate Qaddafi and
speak of a time when he did not exist we
have a history separate when we wore
swooshing had suppressed I think the
beginning I think the monarchy has has
no history personally I think there's a
lot of Muslims perhaps among very old
people
I don't think it has any Houston State
at all neither certainly not in the West
stock
hi guys
first as an Iranian and specialist the
demand of the revolutionaries in 1979
was to bring back a constitutional
monarchy that the original demands
to get rid of us imperialism and then
get rid of the shop so I couldn't avoid
that stating this but the events of the
past four or five weeks have been
tremendously important in the Middle
East and with implications for the rest
of the world actually because we're
hearing of uprisings here and they're
occurring even as far as Hong Kong for
example and and it's really much too
early to making sense as to what is
going to happen what is going to be the
new power structure and so on what's so
interesting to me is that Cairo with all
its power can follow up with in 18 days
whereas the struggle in Libya is going
to continue and certainly it has been
continuing in such places as as Iran so
I wonder what kind of scenarios you can
describe in terms of where the struggles
may be going
and that is one question and if I may
pose another question and that is a
number of colleagues make references to
class and gender composition as well as
women's organization within the context
of the current struggle I wonder whether
you can address this gender question and
it'll bit more because there is there's
really a back of information on this
question and we're not we're not hearing
anything about about what is happening
to genuine question and if you would
provide any sources for us to look after
thank you does it run well I have some
impressions of some of these subjects I
mean not more than that
if you want to say why did the Arab
world seem to lead the way in terms of
sort of the current kind of
international irrelevant movement I
think you have to sort of desk what are
the common basis that we suddenly share
with the Middle East that cut across a
long period of time in the country and
this country sister that say or that of
Europe in which we look at ourselves as
polar opposites and my way of thinking
the answer to that would start out with
neoliberalism it would be a Madison
Wisconsin it would be the destruction of
the middle class and so now sort of
winging this is a kind of global
phenomenon of them that the middle class
all over the world is threatened and
then why is it that the two nations and
the Egyptians and Olivia's and some of
these Yemenis or the lessers that are so
aware of my interpretation is is that
there's an obscene amount of petrol
money sloshing around in these countries
which makes the sort of point that we
all know exists so much more obvious
than even say the Wall Street issues
like here in New York it's sort of lead
the bizarre nature of the sort of
construction of rich and poor it is
blindingly obvious and so I think among
Egyptians to some of my
take some attention to that general idea
is they've come to some sort of
realization that there is no future so
not that they know exactly what that
means except but they know that there's
no reason why they need to exist unless
there's huge social change into a world
which would make them become relevant
and this insight i think is something
that we all have but we all repress
because it applies you know very widely
went there i think it sort of people are
obliged to have a kind of consciousness
that sort of leave it so i mean this is
the third the dead end kind of thing
they look awesome that would be how I
would start out you had a second those
follow up on this I can never forget it
now what you in said it reserved on the
gender issue okay I think there's a bad
habit really studies academic way to
love together something called Islam and
women and to kind of regionalize things
around culture this works if you were
only going to spend one or two minutes
on the subject but it really if you go
into it in a more complicated way I go
with the idea of gender quit ceron all
the stratification systems in the world
and that it distantly is less prominent
in some than others in all it plays this
primitive accumulation role that women
are what the function of women is to be
plundered in other words they're the
ones whose nature it is to do housework
and not going to pay for it so that
vested genere cross-cutting functional
of women in the modern
the first had gender studies is to deny
that the front now but within different
kinds of hegemonies the position of
women is rather different now Libya and
Egypt are extremely different I could
talk a little bit about this this is one
benefit I strike fear any cheap if you
come from the north of countries your
graduate a certain set of universities
of your vaguely middle class and
professional you you've got you emerge
out of a certain kind of context of
limitations and you can do a great many
different kinds of things on the other
hand if you are a woman coming from say
the lower middle classes or the working
classes on Upper Egypt and try the same
thing life doesn't offer to so that
generous blurred
with other considerations now in in
Libya the hegemony really works at what
interval is called custom in other words
kidnap you passed many remarkable gloss
about women and so on paper if your weed
Libyan laws and what mom or could not be
tried to do in terms of Women's Union to
direct democracy summer it's stunning on
the other hand if you then study why is
it that so few Libyan women are able to
sort of benefit and be you know in the
workforce and earning the cast of money
and salaries and prestige that you would
expect well that the answer always is
custom and I believe custom is that eat
logic in other words I think you could
you can do a certain step blame the
society for the logic the human post on
the society and that's how certain time
this kind of structure works in other
words the government can look like it's
above at all but in reality the
government is reproducing a certain kind
of structure in which inhibits people
from achieving things that this is
pretty
a gender issue and Libya would be an
example so that what Libyan women right
and so forth and probably probably the
political writing would show this is
different from egyptian and i think this
would go to Iran and he had a third way
that's a really quick I would like to
just add up to what a professor and
grant said it's very interesting in
berkeley that libya in 1951 we had what
a horrible illiteracy rate and life
expectancy was around 40 years or so
women of course their situation and
literacy was even worse during the
monarchy so they're marvelous comes to
education and actually dictate woman
contrary to that impression we're ahead
of people being a woman in the Gulf and
arrogant pizza they have the right
support since they in the mid-60s and
education has continued in a quiet way
probably this is the most remarkable
from 1951 in that under the two regimes
until today today live expectancy for
women in 70
974 of course it's a very rich country
and there's a lot of ways there but also
remarkable things here we we see the
game woman being very prominent I mean
some University would have 70 or sixty
percent of the higher education ratio
are women in Libya and I'm sorry so
students are some are professors I don't
know whether the ratio for the
professor's but students are really more
than that about fifty percent more than
that than males in the University the
coffee yes nor thieves are you Henry and
you have a woman judges women doctors
women journalists women pilots there
really are coming down in a quiet way
naked women have been actually making
leaves in their own way there or saying
now if you looking for scholars who
wrote Rosen dislike admission to three
Libyan females colors
sir a mad lady she wrote a book about
political culture and libyan dairy
section woman also professor Vanessa
Pharisee who wrote on a very very
important dissertation participation and
I I know that because I wrote the
introduction to that book so has a very
important work and the third one is a
dealer work by a very prominent Libyan
sociologists who works for the UN and
she has been in the humans office in
Saudi Arabia dr. Terry deny laggy
if you were no Arabic there's also a
Yankee worth about a woman journalist
writing and more recently we have fun
Maha dual the antagonist creative writer
and Flores who wrote a book about the
Forgotten women writers so we have now
Libyan women writing their own histories
and they are available in Arabic some
are in English but we have a whole new
generation of lipid novelists with
impulse the Vietnam critics and this is
something I would like to mention and
I'm heart of knows quite a bit about it
and it translated some of it live in
literature because of all the upheavals
that again people were true is the most
outstanding I think Divya short stories
is in my opinion is now among common and
that what are wood and some prominent
things like a sham mother that
economists who was with us over here
here or there other brilliant and men
world-class novelist Ibrahim Kony the
briman foggy and these are it was more
country of 6 million if there really are
very talented writers and some of their
works especially at Coney now translated
in over 40 degrees so I would say if you
looking for something different from
politics an ideological debates I would
advise many of you to read it in
literature because the in Asian the
critique of the regime the displacement
the homes the preparation for a forum
conservative a change in Libya you're
going to find that as in many other
societies and lived in literature they
can all three the good novels and the B
and also creative writing it would
hiccup revolutions whatever Russia or
French or even Iranian Revolution the it
turned to be conservative they think of
Napoleon wanting to be the king of kings
as an outcome of the French Revolution
and before that works fear and Mirage
revolution is a path domin and the
french revolution by plane in the ER n
refers well I think we go that may be
that model of a certain these great
revolutions
possible models were you have prolonged
system of question and then that worries
me but it seems to me that things are
happening at such a scale and that again
the idea of suppressing communication I
mean Ali Sabbah in the oven it has not
been able to sort of prove the clock on
vacation Melanie's it's not going to
happen in Bahrain so in a sense the
ability of people to communicate and the
limits of the repressive regime is 22
put people in jail to suppress these
movements which are largely peaceful it
might be that technology may be playing
a different girl into the processes of
revolutions of the modern era in the
sense that now the ability to sequester
the population is much more difficult
now as to if we think of revolutions
processes that have one stage and
another and another either what is the
next step in Egypt you had very very
possible you know when the shot was was
about to leave
Iran he put some Batiatus Prime Minister
and the next step was to bring someone
on the other side it was all so innocent
in the Prime Minister's resignation
agent today and you want somebody
closest with people seems like in
Tunisia two days before in Egypt and
these are sort of blocking step as to
the same process now where were things
go i think things will go puzzle they
are effectively in these two countries
I'm worried about Libya of course I
think it might go a little longer I
don't know tomorrow's going to be
decisive but simply they have to find
ways of resisting the regime but if
there is nothing for us waiting to go on
back to believe now when will the gender
issue play park some of it has to do
with the role of religion but i think
it's minor i think there is a conviction
ma I'm convinced that that people are
now are looking at Islam for an
inspirational role not so much a bit
wobble there is a lot of religious
reference in the songs but the words
area has not come up at all in Egypt it
hasn't come up in linear it has
in Tunisia and these are over their
differences I service area is not up for
discussion it may come up but I feel
that there is a wee awareness that the
issues are not really over whether these
societies are Muslim or not and these
are societies that are vast the Muslim
leaders and secretary open and Sunni and
so so we have a lot of practical issues
to deal with now when when the
generation come up the law my colleague
said Olivia are all pretty much a lot of
Gaddafi had set up thinking about work
or maybe progressive but I think they
may be helpful for discussion but living
women are are in this neighborhood in
this revolution from the beginning
note to journalists and this has never
happened in Libya to jeremy's that had
been arrested and harassed and when
Qaddafi again being the micro manager
that he is wanted to intervene invited
one to meet with him and she complicated
a fuse she said I don't want to meet
with you this has never happened I mean
you won't say no and this is by a woman
journalist who's become hero the first
in front of my seven and hopefully had
said mr. music indonesia they have a
bore as easy in libya we have owned as
easy which is common as a Pharisee who
was the first person beat this
revolution when her husband was lawyer
where the doors are very active you saw
they be a video of Sanwa Iraqis and some
Cutler get mad I think maybe on
Democracy Now very much in the council
one of them is a work
he running style yep so halfway through
the head and another one not the women
and not we're patient part of the
council these are revolutionary moments
and I'm sure there's lots of sort of
tolerance but I think religions is not
playing a role in the Jewess your disco
sense but more making me in the sort of
the spiritual problem whether it will
play a greater role I doubt it because
the main problem is distribution of
wealth employment and housing and fully
nearly from Florida for that Lisa and
work and I'm the warden provided and
these are in a negotiation where any of
those temporary had told people to not
go to work to unify with the with the
eastern sector and this is not this is a
shake a Muslim chef who's calling for
peaceful protest not yet but peaceful
civil disobedience so already that even
though the Libyan discovers one of our
corner for that they toned wants how
this process of change in I'm gonna
interrupt because I think
we're running over and youth I want to
make an announcement I was hoping to
bring tonight on Billy a member of the
new youth movement in Libya young men
named comin impose he is from vandalism
he's an engineer and he's been
responsible for trying to build up and
cause his communications and he is one
of the lead technicians in building the
satellite television station on the
nineteenth of februari he broadcasted
during the attacks in Benghazi on the
website livestream what was going on and
they reached out to the media and right
now he's sent me a message that the
internet is off in all avidya and there
is I don't want to spread any rumors so
I'll just say that it's not confirmed
that there are bombing runs in different
sections that they come
and that reduce knowledge
he said if he's alive he would like to
plan to come online to talk with us and
he suspects and he's heard that they are
coming to ungodly to destroy the
television station that they're building
so let's hope everything turns out
alright and I'm sorry to depress
everyone
and thank you all really this is a
wonderful opportunity for all of us here
at Columbia and we hope for the best